you that's one of my favorite part about
several of your talks and interviews is
your incredible examples of those
situations and one of my favorites was
you mentioned in a keynote how there was
a model created to detect
criminals and they were able to identify
the pattern the mathematical pattern
between was it like the nose and the and
the edge of your mouth yeah the corner
the corners of the mouth yeah
yeah yeah and
like they were making this huge claim
that there was like this angle theta
that they discovered that was more
indicative of
criminals if it was a smaller angle but
like i was thinking about it and i was
looking at the math and i realized that
what they were describing was the
difference between a smile where you
have a wide angle and a straight face
where you have a much more narrow
hole and i was like wow they really they
really miss the boat on what they're
actually capturing there
so they're
biased yeah wanting to find things that
aren't there
you